blackbeard might have a mythical zone
fruit and by the end of the series his
powers might be so broken that he can
control the seas
big themselves warning if you haven't
caught up with the manga yet but the
last few chapters of one piece were a
complete game changer and that's putting
it lightly so if you haven't caught up
yet go ahead and click off this video
and spend some quality time on this and
we'll see you back here soon okay but
now with that out of the way today we're
making the bittersweet decision that it
might be time to retire some of our
favorite blackbeard devil fruit theories
from throughout the years goodbye
cerberus goodbye to the three brothers
goodbye even to the kraken because given
the big reveal of luffy's own devil
fruit a much more interesting option has
now opened up to us that teach just like
luffy has potentially also eaten a
mythical zone devil fruit the hito hito
no me model moon god
i guess really the jury's still out on
what oda's exactly going to call that
one there's no telling what he will
decide to name the moon god of the
one-piece world but since sun god nika
is an original creation and not directly
borrowed from any mythology in
particular it's unlikely we'll see a
tsukunoyomi or artemis fruit any time
soon instead just like nika blackbeard's
fruit will probably also be based on a
god unique to one piece merging
different cultural ideas what's up amanu
and today we're talking about marshall d
teach and the secret identity of the
yami
i mean for years and years we've
theorized about what blackbeard's own
fruit will be there are just so many
threes associated with teach his three
pistols the three skulls on his flag the
three claws on the weapon that he used
to scar shanks so naturally he'd also
have three devil fruits a logia the yam
yami nominee a paramecia the guragura
and a to be determined zone fruit
we thought for sure that this was
hinting towards a cerberus with its
three hats or a kraken with its three
hearts or something along those lines
maybe blackbeard jumping in and getting
kaido's devil fruit and while all of
these are of course still legitimate
possibilities we have now to welcome a
new theory to the club as well that a
lot of people have been talking about
and obviously i have to throw in my
thoughts on this as well so here we go
so why do we suddenly think that he
actually has a moon god fruit well
because luffy has the sun god fruit of
course luffy and blackbeard have always
been opposites throughout the story they
have always paralleled and mirrored each
other and so if luffy is the sun as you
will see it only makes sense that
blackbeard is the moon the two most
common reoccurring symbols in the story
if you need a little further convincing
though here are just a few ways that
these two characters counter each other
luffy has rubber properties which can
insulate perfectly against the
earthquakes that blackbeard can produce
even though the quake quake fruit is
considered the strongest paramecia with
enough power to destroy the entire world
luffy has a built-in immunity against it
just like he did with annel's lightning
fruit and his awakening can technically
insulate everything around him as well
and now if luffy's a sun god which could
explain his strange ability to produce
flames this runs counter to blackbeard's
darkness fruit those flames are
literally light against the darkness now
it is not just their powers though that
are opposites the parallel between these
two characters run much much deeper than
that and are ingrained in the characters
themselves to their basic fundamental
character level luffy is the warrior of
liberation he brings freedom to the
people he meets on every single island
blackbeard on the other hand leaves a
path of devastation behind him wherever
he goes
[Music]
[Laughter]
very first time we learned about
blackbeard was on drum island and he and
his crew scared of wahpol and his legion
of doctors but also left the villagers
in fear and turmoil however after the
straw heads visit drum island they
liberate the people from wapol's
oppressive rule and leave it as a fresh
new and free kingdom they also acquired
one bonus cotton candy loving radio
mascot on top we also see luffy and
blackbeard as clear opposites in the way
that they attract their crewmates both
luffy and blackbeard brought freedom to
their crew in a sense zorro was
literally released from stockhate nami
from arlong's clutches and robin from
the likes of crocodile and later cp9 and
even the straw hats that weren't freed
from a literal imprisonment they were
freed from a figurative prison usop
sanji and many others were lifted from
their ordinary lives and obligations
luffy was the one who enabled them to
travel the world in pursuit of their
dreams he's someone who gathers strength
from his crewmates and depends on them
but also allows them to chase their own
goals and find their own sense of
fulfillment and yes blackbeard also
frees many of his crewmates from impel
down but it's more so that they can
serve his interest not so they can live
out their own dreams which for most of
the level 5 prisoners you know is
probably just murder actually so maybe
pizarro does feel a deep sense of
fulfillment after all
even the way that luffy and blackbeard
received the devil fruits are clear
opposites luffy's hitohito no me model
nica almost seemed to seek out luffy
specifically the gorosei described it
evading the world government for 800
years as if the fruit has had a will of
its own it really seems like luffy was
actively chosen by the fruit to carry on
the will of joy boy and son got nika and
so contrast this with blackbeard who was
on the hunt for the yummy yummy no me
and murdered his own crewmate thatch in
order to obtain its powers he also
killed his former captain whitebeard in
order to take his fruit as well he
wasn't so much chosen by the fruit as he
sought out that fruit at any moral cost
luffy just innocently taking a bit out
of shanks's treasure just doesn't give
the same vibe as cold-blooded killing
i'd go so far as to say they give off
the exact opposite vibes actually and so
as you can see in so so many ways luffy
and blackbeard while the same in many
ways are also diametrically opposed in
so so many others blackbeard being the
true foil to luffy's main
and so character
if luffy is the sun it makes sense that
blackbeard would be the moon now
obviously the moon is very important to
one piece as a whole as you know if the
sun got nika fruit was foreshadowed even
from the first chapter being titled
romance dawn and from other clues like
the straw hat ship being called a
thousand sunny then you'd think that
there would be a moon god too with how
prominent the moon is overall in the
story here and so here are just a few of
the ways that the moon features heavily
in the series annel's entire goal was to
sail the arc maxime up to the endless
landmass that was the fairy worth and in
his cover story we found that not only
are there space pirates kicking it on
the moon but there are also many
archaeological clues that the winged
rays from the sky islands actually
originally came from the moon in the
library of o'hara we see a planetary
model that shows the one-piece world
having multiple moons the minks
transform into their powerful zulung
forms in the light of the full moon and
the surnames of the wano clans also
contained the kanji for moon for
instance kozuki means light moon
chimotsuki means frost moon and so on
and so forth
[Music]
and the moon isn't just important for
one piece as a whole either it also
seems to hold specific significance for
marshall d teach himself for instance
when ichiro ola drew blackbeard as a
child we see him sitting and crying with
a crescent moon hanging in the sky above
him plus we do know that blackbeard
never sleeps i mean brah this man really
needs to try some melatonin this
insomnia is probably even worse than
mine maybe he too is just too much of a
coffee lover or maybe a moon god is
naturally active and alert at night
would make sense i guess okay so we've
established that due to the parallels
between blackbeard and luffy he probably
possesses a moonga devil fruit however
what exactly does that mean what
abilities could a moon god actually have
well in the same way that you would
expect a sun god to be made out of
rubber what can blackbeard do with his
fruit sure he already has the wildly
strong mastery of earthquakes and
darkness but in the same way that
luffy's new power is broken ruled by his
imagination and the boundlessness of
cartoon logic what borderline
unstoppable powers should we expect from
blackbeard moving forward now as i've
said before many people including me
just assumed that blackbeard will still
have to acquire a mythical zone fruit
later on but as with the cerberus or the
kraken fruit i think it's much more
likely that just like luffy he's had his
mythical zone fruit all along in the
same way that what luffy thought was the
gomugumonomi was actually the hirohitomi
model sango
blackbeard's yami yaminomi might
actually be the moon god fruit this
would of course play wonderfully into
the opposites once again luffy thought
he was a paramecia but was a zone well
blackbeard says he's a logia but he is
actually a zone as well and so while
luffy was totally ignorant of his own
fruit and his powers and honestly still
is blackbeard might very well be aware
of the secret but actively makes other
people ignorant of the true nature of
his abilities the mythical zone fruit
model moon god
wow uh we really need oda to give us the
name for this fruit soon so we know what
to call it anyway the yummy yummy nomi
actually being the moon god fruit makes
a lot of sense i think when blackbeard
fights ace ace actually comments that
blackbeard fruit doesn't feel like a
logia
and you could call a something of an
expert here wielding the miramira no me
it does make sense too because
blackbeard doesn't turn into or generate
darkness he's different from every other
logia fruit user we've met so far
instead the darkness fruit demonstrates
really strange powers he sucks things in
with a power that's much more like
gravity than darkness he can negate
someone else's devil fruit powers when
he makes contact with them again not
something that logically makes sense or
has anything to do with darkness he's
also able to amplify the physical damage
that he himself takes none of these
really makes sense for a darkness
darkness fruit but it could be very much
explained by the mysterious properties
of a mythical zone devil fruit okay
juice
similar to how luffy's powers didn't
make sense for a rubber fruit generating
flames with red hawk changing directions
with the jet covering and even things as
basic as gear second and gear third
don't really make sense without a big
heap of anime logic but in addition to
what blackbeard can already do just like
luffy's awakening unlocked a whole host
of new abilities we will probably get
some wild new powers once the truth of
blackbeard's fruit is fully revealed one
of those powers hitting the subscribe
button but what else could a moon god
possibly do well we do know that oda
takes a ton of inspiration from
mythologies all around the world so
maybe some of the lunar deities from
across the globe can give us some hints
the main egyptian moon god is konzu but
i'll leave that to oscar isaac to
explain that one however the egyptian
god thoth is also connected to the moon
as well as being a god of wisdom and
knowledge and while blackbeard certainly
possesses a lot of secret knowledge this
doesn't scream power up necessarily the
greek moon goddess such as artemis are
often associated with the hunt again
blackbeard doesn't seem connected to
hunting or wild animals but we do see
his crew hunting down powerful devil
fruits like jesus burgess didn't dress
rosa another greek moon god celine has
the power over illusions and while
blackbeard himself again doesn't have
this power himself his crewmate shiryu
and katarina devon use illusions in the
form of invisibility and shape-shifting
also across many many cultures luna
deities are also closely connected to
childbirth but i hope for all of our
sakes that blackbeard's power is not
connected to that because teach is the
last person i would want to see in the
maternity ward honestly now of course
with one piece being a manga we can't
forget about japanese mythology in
shintoism the moon god's goiomi is set
in conflict against the sun god
amaterasu
there's not really much to say about any
inspiration for powers but it's worth
noting that the conflict between these
two gods originated from a fight over
food and that reminds me quite a bit of
a certain argument between luffy and
blackbeard over some giant cherry pies
now of course i'm leaving out one of the
most obvious powers associated with the
moon though one that's especially
significant given that one piece is a
seafaring adventure the moon's gravity
controls the tides of the oceans could
the same gravity of the darkness
darkness fruit control the sea itself i
know i know it sounds crazy since water
is a devil fruit uses weakness but it's
not unheard of for a devil fruit user to
manipulate water indirectly while they
really can't just go for a swim we do
see aokiji frees massive tidal waves at
marineford and charlotte oven boiling
the sea around whole cake islands
and so if blackbeard could influence
tights then he could easily sink
opposing ships and have an advantage in
combat over other devil fruit users he
could for example also make it extremely
difficult to travel to certain islands
in opposition to luffy's liberation he'd
basically literally be restricting
people's freedom to travel could a
previous user of the moon got fruit or
even the original moon god itself be
responsible for phenomena like the
combat and the unpredictable weather of
the grand line we know that devil fruit
awakenings can leave a lasting impact on
the world's landscape just like how
aokiji and the kainu changed punk
hazard's environment forever and so it
would make total sense if a devil fruit
was responsible for the grand line
itself and why not one as powerful as a
potential moon god fruit since luffy's
fruit is boundless and only limited by
its own imagination he needs a foe that
has a similar level of overpoweredness
for lack of a better turn breaking the
taboo between devil fruits and water
would be one way for blackpit to achieve
a borderline broken ability and make for
a more than stellar final fight between
these two antagonists another exciting
possibility aside from control over the
oceans which let's be honest is already
pretty good could have to do with
blackbeard's ability to consume multiple
devil fruits this strange power
exclusive to blackbeard has yet to be
explained especially with this comment
by marco
we know that in jaya luffy and zorro
refer to blackbeard as them as if he had
multiple identities so does the moon god
potentially act as its own entity
separate from teach does it have to do
with the gravity of pulling things in
maybe it's yet another opposite of
luffy's abilities while the sun god
gives freedom and empowerment to others
the moon god is able to take in more
power for itself now so far we've only
talked about blackbeard's powers but if
you really want to understand who teach
truly is and why he's so ridiculously
important to the story you really
shouldn't ignore this next video right
here where i explain his entire
character and the three brothers theory
there's a small cherry on top